i want to mention right away your
co-star uh michael b jordan very funny
guy who's in that clip could not be with
us tonight because his plane
got snowed in is that correct yeah yeah
he was at the super bowl and uh he just
he couldn't make it back in time right
but he sent me a text message you want
me to read on the show and has a good
friend heartfelt loyal companion i i
said i would so says conan i want to
apologize for not making it to your show
the one time i'm on time for a flight
it's canceled because of a snowstorm and
seeing that it is black history month i
know my presence will be deeply missed
call us for emotional all followed by
laughter because i'm sexier and funnier
than you miles
very nice very nice very nice i like it
so far i like it
he's here i feel like uh zach is
probably sitting there just with that
i'm a sex symbol smirk
it's cool because he is jack ephron
that's what's up there we go you know
what
jesus yeah you tell him from now on he
can do all of his segments but i will
you can just text them in
uh let's talk about that all he said
yeah that's i mean that's pretty it
you're sexy and i don't i nobody cares
about it okay i don't know mike thank
you we wish you were here buddy yeah we
miss you he's not watching um
he's out having fun you think he's if
he's glued to the set i've got to see
what they say about me
uh let's talk about this uh it's it
there's a lot of insanity swirling
around you zach how how strange does it
get i mean you have
you hear stories that women have tried
to mail themselves to you
you know things like that that sounds
like sexy and nice
the story he told me was not in that
tone what what do you mean no i said i
was like you can speak freely here i was
like zach what's the craziest thing at
santa's face he's like oh i i had a fan
send me a piece of their skin
what yeah that's what i said i said what
that's dude imagine what i imagine when
i got it yeah yeah it's really you took
it right to the lab to grow a woman
i just like it's such a strange thing
you know it's skin in the mail it's just
hilarious because you don't know how to
handle it you know as a i just it'll
never get around it i love all my fans
i'm very grateful for them but
um it gets weird for miles no even as
like grown women like we were doing this
thing at facebook and uh one of the
girls stood up she said hey uh zach i'm
27. i just had a birthday party all my
plates were high school musical my
napkins were high school musical and uh
my husband said it would be okay if i
hugged you can i hug you
so even these women they're getting
older in life but they still at that
point in their life zach was hanging
above their wall and even though they're
married
it doesn't matter if it's like if zac
efron is in the presence
what's that what's the husband i don't
think about all this and then and then
literally the second after that the
husband's like standing in there and he
goes hey what's up zach yeah how's it
going i'm like oh my gosh dude this is
so awkward hi
how's it going my wife and i would like
you he's like oh no he goes you're the
hall pass he just goes you're like right
now it's cool it's cool it's cool what
do you mean it's cool it's cool it's
cool yeah and i'm going what the [ __ ] is
cool
oh thank you thanks very much but this
is so crazy uh um
yeah there's a lot to talk about there's
a
all right that's the line they cut out
of high school musical
i remember that line really well and
then they had an edit room floor